thank you Adam
hello everyone and a warm welcome to all
of our attendees thank you for joining
the bioprocessing next Leadership Summit
and Expo the topic for this session is
monoclonal antibody early development
and critical considerations for
commercialization success
the agenda for the next hour will be as
follows first I'd like to give a brief
introduction on antibodies and
monoclonal antibodies just to get
everyone particularly any individuals
who may be new to the bioprocessing
world Baseline on what they are and what
they do next we'll talk about the
therapeutic history of monoclonal
antibodies as well as get a glimpse into
their contribution in the current Global
Drug development pipeline third we'll
cover the market ecosystem specifically
the drivers and factors affecting their
development as well as discuss the
overall challenges of bringing a Target
molecule to Market
fourth we'll cover some high-level
regulatory considerations to keep front
of Mind especially during the first in
human trials
next will be the early phase from DNA to
IND or impd filing and explore some
principles that can be employed to
accelerate early development success and
how we as a contract development and
Manufacturing organization approach it
and share a case study after that we'll
turn our attention to the considerations
for the late phase in commercialization
and share a case study as well lastly
we'll wrap up and have a brief q a
portion
to get us started I'd like to pose a few
questions and cover those in this
section what is an antibody what is its
function and how are they produced
antibodies are protein molecules which
traditionally have a characteristic
y-shaped appearance and depending on
their particular class can be found
circulating in the blood in tissue
fluids in mucosal membranes or
secretions and in concert with other
cells and Pathways of the host immune
system act as a sentinel to recognize
and protect the host from foreign
organisms B cells in particular a type
of lymphocyte is where antibodies are
produced
antibody specific protein sequence along
with other post-translational
modifications creates a particular 3D
structure which binds like lock and key
to antigens which are structures on the
outside of foreign substances
antibodies have what are known as
hyper-variable regions which contribute
to their immense diversity and
selectivity and form a pocket to
interact with antigens antigens can be
proteins lipids carbohydrates or nucleic
acids and include viruses bacteria
cancer cells and even common allergens
once antibodies bind to a particular
antigen the immune system responds to
neutralize the foreign entity
this antibody mechanism is leveraged
against infectious disease whether by a
natural infection or vaccine-mediated
immunity polyclonal antibodies are not
identical in sequence or structure and
Target different areas even against a
particular antigen whereas monoclonal
antibodies or maps for short are
identical copies derived from a single
clone or parent B cell and share
identical protein sequence and thus
structure against a particular antigen
and recognize the same antigen with
equal affinity and biological effect
however in combination with recombinant
DNA Technologies engineered antibodies
can be used to treat cancers
inflammatory diseases and autoimmune
illnesses and much more this
illustration on the right shows how
engineered antibodies employ a variety
of mechanisms and Pathways to accomplish
their objective
these engineered antibodies recruit
other cells of the host's immune system
to mount defensive measures
quickly with less off-target effects
often associated with traditional small
molecule drugs
antibodies can also block or otherwise
disrupt cell surface receptors in
corresponding signaling as a mechanism
to modulate disease-related pathways
alternatively antibodies can Target
soluble molecules such as plasma
proteins in either block or sequester
them from regular operation
some monoclonal antibodies called adcs
or antibody drug conjugates are designed
to carry a drug a radioactive agent or
another molecule and deliver that
payload to the cell targeted by the
antibody interaction
there are also other monoclonal
antibodies called bi-specific antibodies
which are engineered to recognize two
different antigens and thus bring
different target cells into close
proximity of each other for an intended
biological effect
maps are a potent effective and proven
therapeutic in modern medicine but we'll
focus specifically on traditional labs
in today's presentation
therapeutic monoclonal antibodies are
the output of complex biological
processes simplistically the production
of a map has both upstream and
downstream procedures the Upstream
process deals with creating the ideal
cellular Factory and includes cell line
development clone selection media
optimization growth and scaling up from
smaller bench scale to larger bioreactor
volumes and finally the Harvest and
collection of the cells
the goal of the Upstream process is to
leverage the cell's innate ability to
produce the desired functional
monoclonal antibody with maximum output
and minimum time
the downstream process serves to isolate
and purify the desired monoclonal
antibody from the cell's environment
with maximum impurity and minimum loss
the entire process is supported by a
quality control steps automation
Technologies and analytical methods to
ensure reproducible output and
biological activity from run to run and
as the scale increases
maps are a product of the process which
relies on a large number of material
inputs instrumentation procedural steps
and Technical decisions Thermo Fisher is
one supplier offering an expansive
portfolio along a Continuum of
bioprocessing from media to mixers cell
lines to centrifuges resins to
refrigerators and much more
in this next section the questions being
addressed are what part have monoclonal
antibodies played in human therapies and
for how long
what level of contribution do maps play
in the current Global Drug development
Pipeline and what does the ownership
profile of these molecules look like
since the fda's initial approval of its
first therapeutic monoclonal antibody
back in 1986 to treat organ transplant
rejection the number of maps has
exceeded 100 different approved
molecules as of 2021. with multiple
molecules undergoing regulatory review
while cancer Remains the primary
indication treated by monoclonal
antibodies
at nearly 50 percent the breadth of
indications has expanded to include
neurological diseases genetic diseases
and infectious diseases like stars Cove
2 just to name a few
a large portion of the top 20
Therapeutics by annual total sales is
accounted for by Maps well-known
Therapeutics like Humira for rheumatoid
arthritis
intruda and opdivo for various cancers
in stellar and Remicade for psoriasis
and digestive disorders are just a few
of the billion dollar monoclonal
antibody Blockbusters that are both
life-saving and life-changing for
countless people worldwide
Global cumulative sales of map
Therapeutics are estimated to be north
of 100 billion dollars U.S in 2021 and
projections into 2025 are expected to be
greater than 150 billion dollars U.S and
growing double digits annually
a 2022 Thermo Fisher analysis of Pharma
intelligence is Pharma project Day 2021
database which represents the Global
Drug development and research pipeline
indicates Maps as the most common
modality in the overarching biologic
segment when compared to a host of other
biologic molecule types in the
pre-clinical phase shown in the bottom
left blue section nearly 1 000
monoclonal antibodies comprise almost 40
percent of the potential biologics in
development
in the clinical trials phases shown to
the right Mass account for 40 to 45
percent of the overall pipeline by
number with almost 300 monoclonal
antibodies in Phase One 266 in Phase 2
and 162 molecules in Phase 3 trials
while by specific monoclonal antibodies
and antibody drug conjugates showed the
greatest increase year over year from
2020 to 2021 traditional monoclonal
antibodies continue to contribute
significantly in the global therapeutic
pipeline
another takeaway from the analysis is
the ownership of the pre-clinical and
clinical pipeline is significantly owned
by small and emerging biopharma
companies as shown in the chart on the
left
small and emerging biopharmers own 90 of
the pre-clinical biologic molecules some
2300 plus compounds and approximately 70
percent of the biologics in the clinical
trials phases which again include
significant representation by monoclonal
antibodies
he's small and emerging companies lack
the capital Advanced development
capabilities and the manufacturing
expertise and thus frequently partner
with cdmos like thermal Fisher
Scientific to develop and commercialize
their molecules
on the right side chart speed of
development and speed to Market has been
increasing as the number of drugs
approved with accelerated regulatory
designation has increased the desire to
fill unmet needs for serious medical
cons conditions has brought
about various regulatory enhancements
over time including accelerated
approvals priority review procedures
improved communication with health
agencies as well as leveraging surrogate
and or intermediate clinical endpoints
to bring more effective solutions to
Market more quickly while maintaining
stringent safety standards regulations
and improved clinical benefits
in the last decade the number of drugs
approved under a regulatory sorry under
an accelerated designation has climbed
from roughly 50 percent to the mid 70
mark
in light of the position Maps occupy in
the Global Drug development pipeline
what other outside drivers are affecting
the ecosystem of map development and for
that matter the overall biologics
segment what specific Market forces are
affecting sponsor companies and lastly
what are some inherent phase specific
challenges in developing and
commercializing a monoclonal antibody
let's dig into those questions here
the map development ecosystem is complex
and contains various opposing drivers
first speed matters to innovators
because a human patient is ultimately
waiting for these life-saving drugs
patients especially those with rare
conditions need new and more effective
medicines faster
the small and emerging biotech company
is particularly under time pressure to
go from DNA to IND or impd filing so
they can show investors progress that's
being made which in turn allows them to
secure additional funding based on
Milestones achieved second the biologics
development pipeline is growing more
complex specialty drugs including
biologics cell and Gene Therapies
and other first-in-class new modalities
are increasing not decreasing the
intricacies of how biologics are
developed and manufactured
cdmos are frequently being tapped to
provide this technical capability to
reduce the learning curve and to
accelerate the path to commercialization
third while small and emerging
pharmacists may be fighting year to year
to survive large farmers are not immune
from their own Financial challenges they
have seen declining r d return on
investment over the past decade large
farmers are supplementing internal
Discovery through mergers Acquisitions
or partnership deals with small and
emerging companies or even other myths a
large size Pharma companies to drive the
speed to Market and maximize what
earning potential can be had
fourth the covet pandemic demonstrated
the importance
of the important role a trusted cdmo or
CMO can play in helping deliver product
urgently whether Outsourcing a lower
priority project so the innovator can
focus on higher priority programs or
leveraging the contract Partners agility
and capacity to deliver drug substance
and or drug product
the pandemic also highlighted the need
to evaluate multiple sourcing streams to
both meet demand and prevent unexpected
supply chain deficiencies
lastly the increasingly digitized world
we all live in is also transforming the
Pharma ecosystem
big data is driving workflow insights Ai
and machine learning are aiding molecule
design and prediction and increasingly
interconnected Digital Data Systems are
improving efficiency decision making
real-time visibility and innovation
in summary there are multiple changing
Dynamics applying pressure to all the
players involved who are trying to
enable new Therapeutics in less time
to put a point on the aforementioned
challenge of Roi on R D spend looking at
the 10 years preceding the covid-19
pandemic a 2019 Deloitte report
indicated R D returns of 12 large cap
bile Pharma companies went from 10 in
2010 down to
2 in 2019 as shown on the left side
chart the chart on the right side showed
during the same time period the average
forecast peaked sales per asset shrunk
50 percent from 816 million dollars U.S
in 2010 to 376 million dollars U.S in
2019. so on the one hand the cost of
bringing a molecule to Market has
increased significantly while on the
other hand forecasted Peak sales have
dropped almost that same percentage
making the entire Financial equation
that much more challenging over time
as if the market ecosystem challenges
weren't enough the actual development
phases have their own Associates
challenges
at the highest level the path to
commercialization of a new monoclonal
antibody has four main steps they are
early Discovery and research followed by
development next the clinical trials
phases which seek to establish safety
and efficacy and finally assuming
everything is successful scaling to the
appropriate volume for the intended
commercial target market
let's take a deeper look at the
associated challenges by development
phase and opportunities and
considerations at a high level
the objective of the early Discovery and
research phase is to identify a
candidate map molecule to be able to
enter first in human trials
the goal here is to optimize the r d
efforts at the bench while stretching
investment dollars made while also
trying to drive the timeline down
this is where the hard science is being
done however as my process development
colleagues tell me not all monoclonal
antibodies behave as well in real life
as they do on paper and the implications
of each molecule's inherent scalability
predictability and stability will carry
over into the subsequent process
development phase
some opportunities to overcome the
challenges in this phase include
leveraging new and emerging Technical
Innovations to improve Precision
increase throughput expand parallel
processivity and automation
for those performing technical transfers
to a cdmo during this early phase
performing comprehensive Gap assessments
can inform on both raw material and
capability concerns which may bring
about further technical evaluations
digitizing data transfer at this early
stage can improve accuracy while
reducing human error and effort
lastly leveraging platform cell lines
and or platform processes can help get
new molecules to and through the proof
of concept phase for many leveraging a
cdmo and the experience they gained over
multiple iterations is an invaluable
asset
in the development phase you've proven
the molecule is safe and the candidate
is able to move forward now it's all
about mastering the recipe pulling the
various levers to build a robust
informed productive and scalable process
for healthy cells and maximum monoclonal
antibody yield in upstream and
downstream processes leading into phase
two and phase 3 trials the main
challenge
is to conduct the full design of
experiment efforts to generate
sufficient data at the process specific
and product specific levels another
relevant consideration at this stage may
be determining facility fit meaning
capacity Quality Systems total
capabilities and availability for
clinical trials material and Beyond this
to avoid unnecessary switching insights
or suppliers stemming from capacity
limitations
some opportunities to overcome the
challenges in this phase include being
able to rely or focus on a critical
platform knowledge or those Elements
which are largely conserved or very well
known in other words knowing which
variables you can and should adjust
there's also opportunity to leverage a
number of technically Advanced High
throughput automation systems which can
drastically accelerate key steps which
we'll mention a little later
lastly it's important to identify and
characterize key ranges for
manufacturing to avoid deviations that
would cause failures down the line
in the trials phase the goal is to
achieve the trial objectives for
effectiveness of the molecule in
question
however it's critical to consider the
impact of scaling production to the
yield and quality requirements of not
only the number of patients being dosed
but also for resupply needs in advance
the question of how much material is
needed is usually front and center but
having a manufacturing partner who can
effectively match potentially change in
clinical demands is a great Safeguard
some opportunities to overcome the
challenges in the clinical trials phase
include having a responsive
manufacturing partner who can coordinate
raw materials via exceptional
communication and forecasting it also
helps having a partner who's buying
power and scale can be leveraged to
ensure continuity of critical Supply
the number of bioreactors total capacity
distribution of bioreactors and various
geographies helps provide the ability to
adjust to production based on clinical
demand and or changes in demand due to
dosing requirements
lastly having a reliable and integrated
partner for clinical trials and
Logistics support which encompasses
patient recruitment patient management
distribution and clinical packaging is a
smart approach
being able to launch a commercial
product to meet patient needs is the
true end however achieving and
maintaining commercial quality in scale
presents its own challenges the process
must be stress tested and critical
parameters must be fully characterized
validated and controlled at production
scale and a sufficient number of batches
to support bla filing post bla
continuous process verification must
occur to ensure ongoing quality ensure
compliance and enable continuous
Improvement
opportunities to overcome challenges in
this phase include standardized
templates and approaches standardized
training regimens site-wide alignment
across sites for documentation controls
and Sops to reduce timelines while
approving overall cohesiveness and
leveraging surrogates instead of actual
product or process Solutions
before we get into the phase specific
apply principles and case studies it
behooves us to address some key
regulatory considerations as precursors
to long-term success particularly in the
area of first and human trials in this
section we will address what should be
the right approach toward regulatory
concern what are some benefits from
having an early and strategic regulatory
plan and how does advanced communication
with regulatory agencies help with
critical first and human trials
or small and emerging Pharma companies
in particular the CMC or chemistry
manufacturing and controls activities
are sometimes siled planning a
well-vetted CMC strategy particularly
for first and human dossier preparation
and entering the clinic means
CMC regulatory must be an early and
engaged partner in all aspects of drug
development discussions from
pre-clinical to clinical
proactive CMC planning helps to progress
through the subsequent phases and
towards licensing and marketing
it's important to keep the patient and
clinical experience in mind for example
consider what product changes could be
clinically meaningful when transitioning
from the toxicology batch to the first
and human batch
those manufacturing changes that alter
impurity profiles or affect potency and
these outcomes begin to build product
knowledge to inform future product
development stages
the pressure to be nimble requires
having a farther Horizon for
manufacturing development inclusive of a
regulatory strategy which can help with
identifying early versus later data
requirements for the dossier mitigating
bottlenecks as the clinical program
expands to later phases as well as
expanding to new jurisdictions and
understanding regulatory nuance and
difference
and also shaping conversations with
Regulators for example having
transparent productive discussions about
proposed comparability approaches
Regulators have mechanisms to meet with
sponsors in advance of a first and human
trial submission so why should you do it
one Regulators can get to know you your
company and your molecule
two it's an opportunity to gain feedback
formal feedback to CMC strategies and
future development plans while
benefiting from the regulator's
knowledge expertise regarding
regulations and experience based on
other similar products which may be able
to help identify and avoid unnecessary
development studies
three it can allow for alignment on
content and expectations to avoid CMC
clinical holds and costly delays to
reach certain milestones
this is particularly important for novel
products and new manufacturing processes
to get early buy-in and approval
some best practices to take are first
Regulators know the science but they
don't know your product or your process
so the CMC dossier must answer the why
why early specifications were sent why
purification steps were chosen based on
expected impurities
preventing gaps in the story helps
ensure a successful dossier
second write the cmc.ca to fit the
broadest possible audience keeping the
dossier jurisdiction neutral allowing it
to be used for other jurisdictions to
facilitate future life cycle flexibility
thirdly plan to include key CMC
highlights and plans in the pre-filing
meeting to advise what's coming next in
the dossier
the best time to seek regulatory
feedback should take into consideration
your overall timeline to enter the
clinic and engage Regulators early
enough to fill out time for
consideration of their feedback and make
adjustments in your development plans
now let's jump into the early phase
development going from DNA sequence to
IND or impd filing in this section we'll
look at what principles to employ to
accelerate early development and how
Thermo Fisher scientific's quick to
clinics service offers that to our
clients how technology can help reduce
risk and how risks taken need to be
relative to the overall reward
before we get into the mechanisms to
accelerate early development timelines
we ought to understand the headwinds
facing a candidate monoclonal antibody
molecule and understand why a healthy
Pipeline and Urgent timeline are both
critical
based on a 2021 report co-authored by
bio informa and qls called the 2021
clinical development success rates
2011-2020
Maps had an overall likelihood of
approval of 12 meaning from Phase 1 to
final FDA approval rating approval
during that 10-year period
as shown on the left chart
other modality likelihoods of approval
range from as low as five percent to as
high as 17 percent
looking phase by phase shown on the
table on the right Maps had a 55
probability of success from phase one to
two a 34 success rate from two to three
and a 68 rate of success from phase 3 to
ndabla with almost 100 success rate for
final approval from ndabla
the average time to receive an approval
during that 10-year period was
approximately 10 and a half years with
faster candidates taking approximately
nine years and slower ones averaging
about 12 years
my Fallout rates and lengthy development
timelines necessitate a large and
continually fresh pool of candidate Maps
if the market is going to see material
editions of new Therapeutics over time
with 90 percent of all drugs failing to
make it through clinical trials along
with decade-long development and
approval Cycles innovators are trying
diligently to accelerate the first step
of getting to the clinic with a new Mad
candidate but how can that best be done
We Believe three main principles provide
a proper framework at a high level those
are one leverage advancements in
technology to accelerate development the
specifically increased productivity
automation Precision control and quality
two careful construction and
parallelization of drug substance and
Drug product related activities and
timelines as well as pre-qualification
of common vial formats and third
leverage prior process experience proven
platforms established protocols and
templated processes to reduce time while
ensuring risks taken are relative to
actual reward
Thermo fissures enhanced quick to clinic
for biologic service is based on those
principles and gets clients from DNA to
IND or impd filing in less than 13
months for igg-1 and igg4 monoclonal
antibodies We Believe 13 months is a
healthy balance between speed and
appropriate risks
clients provide us the starting DNA
sequence and in turn they receive
released drug substance and Drug product
which includes one month stability data
quality reviewed reports and a CMC
regulatory dossier ready for filing
along the path we leverage the gibco
freedom Xbox commercial ready cell line
to provide a four to five month cell
line development timeline to final clone
selection
also a dual Vector system to control
heavy and light chain
expression ratios cgmp Wholesales banked
and chemically defined media free if any
animal derived components and a
favorable licensing program with no
royalty payments exit fees clinical
Milestone payments or regulatory support
fees which helps to accelerate the
project initiation and set up our
clients for long-term financial success
we perform formulation screening rather
than full formulation development to
accelerate the process additionally
utilizing our own mam workflow or
multi-attribute method which is an lcms
based protein quality attribute
quantitation platform allows for more
information to make better and faster
decisions in the Upstream process
development steps but more importantly
creates a solid analytical foundation
for critical scale up activities on the
path to eventual commercialization
another key benefit is a seamless drug
substance to drug product handoff
process leveraging Thermo fissures
experience and expertise in sterile fill
finish at established manufacturing
sites in North America Europe and soon
to be expanding into Asia
optional clinical trial packaging and
labeling can be supported as needed
from transfection to filing the green
highlighted steps shown here are the
optimized constructed and adjusted steps
to speed up the timeline to the clinic
while balancing risk and quality
we leverage a host of enabling
Technologies in cell line and cell
culture development and monoclonality
assessment which we'll cover in the
following slide
analytical method establishment is
pulled forward as early as possible and
use of transient material gives speed
whenever appropriate
we use a strategic mix of binding Elisa
and the man workflow and other platform
methods for analytical method
establishment
co-qualification during analytical
development between drug substance and
Drug product sites enables concentration
in ID assays to be done together rather
than separately
parallel execution of Upstream process
development and cell line development
workflows collapses the overall timeline
we have confirmation runs and toxicology
batches performed at the same time to
understand robustness of the process
while generating tax material and lastly
coordinated shipment between drug
substance science and Drug product sites
help to reduce the inherent lag time
advances in bioprocessing technology
include higher expressing cell lines
improved bio reactor performance
increasing single-use capabilities at
ever increasing scales and higher
throughput screening tools these have
all helped maximize output while
reducing effort and time on the front
end we leverage the Berkeley lights
Beacon optifluidic platform which allows
for single cell
clone in C2 antibody titer assessments
as well as the Sartorius Amber 15 mini
bioractor which allows for parallel
growth and productivity evaluations
as previously mentioned we employ our
own lcms based analysis and the Amber 15
bioreactor is in parallel with the CLD
steps as we scale up to cgmp batches to
develop the best growth conditions while
ensuring stability and product quality
as such we are able to shave six to
eight weeks of Time Versus traditional
methods while still having confidence in
the lead clone with the high level of
simultaneous process knowledge
these attributes contribute to a client
being able to accelerate a molecule from
concept to clinic however to gain some
of that speed some flexibility is
necessarily sacrificed as such this
offering only focuses on early phase
first and human supports only
liquid-filled bile formats and follows a
proven but limited flexibility template
of both process and documentation
I'd like to share a quick case study of
one of our quick to Clinic clients in
this case clients say late stage
clinical biopharma with operational
footprint in the Middle East the area
Focus centers on the Discovery
development and commercialization of
first in class cancer treatments the
candidate molecule was a traditional
igg-1 map which made it a perfect fit
for our offering however this client was
pretty conservative and also relatively
new to biologics at the time our team
responded quickly presented them the
benefits of leveraging our solution to
get them to Clinic fast we held
face-to-face meetings to review our
capabilities and present the benefits of
our platform Solutions which piqued
their interest they signed on to our
initial quick to Clinic offering we'll
call it version 1.0 and also added
elements of our cryptic care or fully
integrated offering which I'll speak to
next
Thermo Fisher Pharma Services Group
provided them solid Insight on clinical
strategy and timing of studies to
support the pre-ind meeting this was
back in 2020. this client fully
leveraged the global logistics footprint
of our drug substance and Drug product
Network and is now currently on our
version 2.0 quick to Clinic offering and
presently the IND is pending second half
of 2022 completion
now despite all the emphasis on speed to
Clinic
chip a good thing can be a not so good
thing as such we like to present three
pitfalls to avoid on the road to IND and
impd speed shouldn't be prioritized over
other critical success factors
time pressures can result in missed
opportunities poorly considered platform
selection inadequate material for
scale up or clinical trials or even
unsatisfactory analytics data for IND
and impd applications each of these
risks have become significant financial
time regulatory or Logistics problems at
the point of application or Beyond
to avoid jeopardizing your IND impd
while still maintaining aggressive
timelines consider the following
strategies one leverage integrated drug
substance drug product programs to shave
time without sacrificing other T metrics
this means taking advantage of platform
products and standardized offerings were
relevant and available achieving
efficiency through high throughput
automation Technologies and most
importantly parallel and concurrent
characterizations and analytical method
qualifications
especially with a partner who has had
demonstrated success and experience
two thoughtfully consider risks and
potential future impact on filing on
scale up and other future goals each
accelerated step skipped or altered to
save time should be fully evaluated
smart and thorough toxicology testing
confirmatory satellite runs standardized
protocols and advanced screening
Technologies can enable Smart yet rapid
progress with relatively low risk
lastly work with experienced Partners
who understand process development and
scale of challenges experience gives an
invaluable insight to creative and
credibility especially if they
participated in the full development
process many times for a variety of
molecule types
any partner should be one with deep
experience in both traditional and
accelerated process this to protect both
parties from unrealistic expectations
and unforeseen quality concerns or
delays
finally the IND or intd quickly
shouldn't mean putting the blinders on
to Future scale-up scope analytics
practical costs or Logistics these may
seem like far off factors they're
relevant to early decision making but
they can make or break the success of a
drug product during clinical testing or
commercialization
to reduce risk of future platform
changes or Force cell line
re-evaluations scalability should be
considered sooner rather than later
ways to increase scalability success
include harnessing robust platform
processes
starting with a strong platform process
selection is an essential step working
with the development and Manufacturing
partner with the robust platform process
that identifies components
that can be standardized can remove the
burden of starting from scratch for each
drug substance ideally a standardized
platform process should work reliably
and predictably from inoculation to fill
finish relying on better Technologies
with performance history
our own standardized platform features
harvesting viral inactivation
chromatography filtration buffer fill
finish and storage practices and
equipment that meet and or exceed
industry standards
starting with a thoughtful framework
leads to fewer surprises after approval
in terms of materials scalability and
quality
also consider the fees payments and
Licensing implications understanding
these costs up front and how sustainable
they will be at the point a scale up is
essential to an economically viable
product consider how molecules are
licensed whether royalties or clinical
Milestone fees is regulatory support
included in the license do the host cell
research rights allow for contract
development or Manufacturing
are there exit fees are there
opportunities to reduce fees through
upfront payments or other options
Pitfall 3 occurs when the focus is only
on phase one trial needs however
neglecting to follow proper testing and
documentation can be an obstacle to
Swift IND or impd approval or limiting
the potential product knowledge learned
from early research studies
early phase clinical work has very
different requirements than late phase
and commercial use in terms of process
efficiency production costs and timeline
Supply yield scalability product
delivery performance and storage what's
sufficient for small-scale
pharmacokinetic and pharmacodynamic
studies and first in human proof of
concept studies may not be practical to
scale or maintain in future clinical
development stages or after marketing
authorization
identifying critical requirements for
filing and phase one initiation and how
production needs will change as the
molecule advances allows for early
planning to provide an advantage for
approval transfer future research and
commercialization
companies can proactively support Indi
and PD approval and downstream
transitions by having experienced
regulatory experts document and GAP
assess all CMC elements for IND
submission as we stated during the
earlier key regulatory consideration
section it's important to work with
knowledgeable and experienced CMC
partners and to employ those best
practices mentioned
working with a partner with capabilities
Beyond drug substance and Drug product
development and Manufacturing
ahead to a partner who can readily
transition you out of phase one into the
next phases of clinical development in
larger trials a contract partner with
experience in all stages of post
Manufacturing Services can make the
long-term experience more streamlined
more predictable and ultimately
simplified
with an eye on a future
commercialization it's important to
think about label design final packaging
storage and distribution and Logistics
so what about the rest of the
development phases and what principles
are important when moving to late phase
and Commercial launch what are some of
the challenges facing innovators as they
navigate this phase are there ways to
reduce obstacles and hindrances on the
way to Market
historically innovators hop from vendor
to vendor from phase to phase to
essentially shop for the best phase
specific partner that approach meant
multiple service and quality agreements
to review and negotiate as well as
multiple invoices to reconcile it also
meant no single entity was accountable
for the overall program
each vendor was responsible only for
their part of the equation
technical transfers and development
phase transitions would necessarily have
to occur between different companies and
sites with very different levels of
communication and collaboration the flow
of regulatory information from phase to
phase and Company to company can be
burdensome if not centrally managed too
transportation of materials that have to
be organized between different cdmos
manufacturing sites clinical trial sites
and distribution Network locations
innovators would expand considerable
effort time and resource to coordinate
all the disparate steps involved and in
the end the innovators carried nearly
all the risk
whereas the enhanced quick to clinic for
biologics offering mentioned previously
is geared for Speed and early phase only
our quick to care offering covers the
entire Continuum from early development
through late phase clinical Supply into
commercialization it's our fully
flexible and fully integrated offering
which changes the historically
fragmented approach where individual
vendors or cdmos are only responsible
for one part to one where an innovator
can effectively start here and stay here
from concept to patient and gain a
myriad of benefits from having a single
solution provider the program success is
due to a comprehensive and integrated
drug substance to drug product plan
supported by a single program manager
dedicated to the project who acts as the
client's point of contact to ensure full
visibility and control
the program manager integrates all of
our capabilities including the power of
a large Global Network of subject matter
experts facilities and capabilities and
ensures communication and governance to
ensure rapid decision making raising
awareness of issues and proper oversight
operational efficiencies are gained in
terms of technical transfers being able
to leverage shared documentation as well
as internal process owners common or
shared equipment knowledge approved
vendors are Universal across all our
sites and greater visibility to allow
for dynamic changes in capacity or
localized Supply challenges
in short coordination commitment and
communication are working to ensure
accountability for the client regardless
of if they're a large Pharma customer or
a two-person virtual biotech
the program also offers other benefits
in providing a single service agreement
harmonized quality agreements integrated
and combined proposals for efficiency
and still saves an average of 14 weeks
of time from start to finish
the quick to Care Program covers our
large molecule and biologics portfolio
but also extends to small molecule drug
substance oral solid dose sterile drug
product and most recently our cell and
Gene Therapy Services offering too one
unique benefit of quick to care is our
clinical Supply optimization service
which works with clients to define the
clinical Supply strategy which includes
forecasting Dynamic reforesting
experienced supply chain managers and
different geographies and therapeutic
areas to ensure clients have the right
medication in the right place with the
right label
total transportation management is
another benefit which provides a Global
Network of carriers dispatch control
services a Global Network of cold chains
storage facilities customs and
Regulatory support insurance and full
inventory control to ensure end-to-end
Supply
if you think quick to care is only for
larger more established Pharma customers
think again quick to care is ideal for
clients who have minimal internal
support who lack expertise who have
complex trial designs who need
flexibility and for those who expect
variable resource demands throughout the
trial
here's a quick case study on one of our
quick to care clients we had two clients
who are working together one
headquartered in Europe the other in
Asia both focusing on cancer biologics
the target molecule was a traditional
monoclonal antibody and one of the
partners had been working with Thermo
Fisher Scientific and had completed
phase two development they actually
tried shopping for another cdmo for
phase three but ultimately came back to
Thermo Fisher the two companies had
Divergent company cultures needs and
expectations
CMC strategy was a critical need for
both and a partner with the global
approach was extremely important to them
they leveraged the quick to care
offering as an ideal solution including
three sites in our Network Princeton New
Jersey for development groaning in in
the Netherlands for drug substance
production and ferrantino Italy for a
drug product production
the governance and collaboration
benefits of our program streamlined
total communication between clients and
sites and allowed for Clear escalation
when necessary
early on face-to-face regulatory
alignment facilitated a streamlined
approach and despite the early days of
the pandemic affecting travel PPQ was
still accomplished and successfully
navigated
the bla was submitted in the second half
of 2021 and is now pending health agency
approval
before I summarize the main points
covered today I would like to express a
data gratitude to my colleagues in the
Pharma Services Group as well as those
in the bio production group who have
provided me this opportunity to speak a
very special thanks to my colleagues in
The bioprocess Sciences group the
scientific and Technical Affairs team
the process development team as well as
my partners in Global Marketing for
helping with all the site content and
finally thank all of you for your
attendance and attention
in summary monoclonal antibodies have
filled and will continue to fill a very
critical role in the global therapeutic
pipeline the pressure is driving speed
to clinic and speed to patients are
diverse and challenging and require
careful balance between risk and reward
three elements to consider are one how
and where you can optimize in the early
stages to get to First in human trials
by leveraging technology to accelerate
development while reducing risk and
considering careful construction and
parallelization of drug substance and
Drug product activities two remember the
three pitfalls IND impd at all cost IND
impd over everything else and focusing
only on phase one Supply needs the three
for late phase bear in mind what is your
clinical Supply strategy do you have the
transportation management piece lockdown
do you prefer managing a decentralized
network of vendors and suppliers or
should you go with an integrated
solution provider finally speed to
successful IND impd and Beyond is
achievable when companies leverage
integrated programs adopt robust
platforms and align with Partners
offering full service support and
experience and Regulatory submissions
thank you